[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
return of Rhett McLaughlin Rhett
McLaughlin from Rhett and Link Rhett and
Link we're on I guess it was a couple
years ago they are incredible YouTube
Sensations comedy Sensations and just
wonderful people but last time Rhett was
on he was sort of not yet ready to
discuss his faith and sort of some adapt
adaptions that's not a word Evolutions
uh some changes let's go with changes uh
he wasn't yet ready to talk about that
so we sort of got this like weird
stilted feeling last time it was on he's
since put out an incredible record that
I enjoy a lot a lot a lot it's called
human overboard
uh which you can check out now obviously
wherever you stream your music Rhett
McLaughlin human overboard so he's come
out quite a bit about his faith and in a
beautiful in in beautiful music form so
we were able to have a more interesting
and open conversation this time around
and we also just were Silly beans he's a
very very fun guy very very interesting
guy and we were Silly billies and I'm
really glad you guys are here to check
it out I hope you enjoy if you want to
see me be a silly Billy live go to
petehomes.com got some tour dates coming
up thank you to everybody that came to
Chicago Boston Atlantic City and Toronto
those shows were great next up is San
Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte and Washington D.C tickets for
all of those can be found at
petehomes.com and if you like this
podcast why not get nasty with it what
does that mean it means try a pizza pick
this isn't I didn't even get this I'm
holding up for people watching it on
video not even I didn't fetch this for
the ad this is just constantly on my
desk what is it it's a empty bottle of
magic mind here it is matcha boosts your
energy adaptogens helps you relax
nootropics or new atropics I've heard to
pronounce both ways nootropics keep you
focused and honey because it makes you
happy that's basically what it is it's a
productivity drink it's not an energy
drink maybe you've heard me offer it to
the guests on the show
the reason is sponsorship aside I found
these guys through my friend James
bashara and it's absolutely changed my
life and then I reached out I was like
let's get a promo code for the weirdos
but it is absolutely a true Pete's pick
in the sense that I use it I use it
every single day Val uses it every
single day and there's nothing I found
that is not only a great caffeine
substitute but also just a good caffeine
co-pilot meaning if you take it in the
morning with your coffee the adaptions
round out the edges that are sometimes
kind of staticky and stressful of too
much caffeine so it Smooths out the
experience but also gives you those
pneumotropics I'm going to say new
atropics this time that help you think
Lions main natural things that help your
noodle uh Focus dial in don't expect
wired expect dialed in it's got 12
functional ingredients including matcha
which I already uh you know which I
already said sorry I couldn't find the
word said it's created to be taken daily
for a sharper mind steady energy immune
support and less stress you get 30
percent more done on average that's five
to seven hours of thirty percent more
productivity after drinking when I'm on
the road one of the things I love about
it as opposed to something like coffee
which is way too much caffeine for me
taking this and knowing that it'll be
clean out of me in about five hours able
to sleep it doesn't give you those
Jitters it doesn't keep you awake but
helps your mind dial into that perfect
productivity creativity and honestly
like a really mood elevated Zone magic
mind is the daily morning drink for
creators entrepreneurs comedians I'm
going to add Comedians and Freelancers
athletes have Gatorade now creators have
creatorade like I said it's not wired
dialed in I've turned so many of my
writer friends onto it my Creator
friends my comedian friends it is
absolutely 100 no [__] a secret weapon
in my Arsenal I travel with it I have it
in my car I have it in my carry-on I
absolutely love it so try it 15 to 30
minutes before you need something done
you need to get into that flow State you
will fall in love I promise helps fight
off procrastination brain fog fatigue
and even some ADD symptoms getting you
into that flow State and we have a
special offer for weirdos from our
friends at magicmind all you have to do
is go to magicmind.com
weird and use my discount code at
checkout weird to get a limited 20 off
your first order that's
www.magicmind.com
weird and use promo code weird for 20
off and you know get your caffeine game
dialed in I really think this is the
stuff of the future meaning we're going
to look back on these times like Mad Men
and be like how are we only drinking
coffee either drink this instead or
drink this with your coffee there will
be no turning back I promise it's an
absolute absolute Game Changer all right
that's it let's listen to Rhett
McLaughlin my dear friend he was amazing
he was hilarious and be sure to check
out his record human overboard I really
really loved it I think you guys will
there's a lot of heart and a lot of soul
in there we talk a lot about the record
here and be sure to go to petehomes.com
if you want to see me on the road
alright everybody get into it
well it seems where you belong you
belong in like a wooded
look at these two giants yeah man two
two [__] two big guys on a is this a
love seat or is it a couch well to us
it's a love seat
anyone else we make a couch a love seat
red and Pete make a couch a loveseat
yeah it sort of Rhymes it's nice to see
you man it's been a long time yeah
looking at your face it was definitely
pre-pandemic pre-pan yeah and it was you
and the and the the other guy link uh we
we sometimes the before picture yeah and
then you go on a quest and then the
after picture well it was yeah right
with an act I'm not even teasing him I'm
just like he's like a regular guy and
then you come out of the portal and it's
like oh my god what happened he was
harrowed yeah he fought a whale yeah man
like this I just embraced it you know
yeah yeah I embraced it completely and
then if you clean up you look like him
again well what what well what happened
was is now you know I see I can look at
pictures of myself before this happened
and I you mean this yeah yeah I'm like
that guy didn't spend as much time on
his hair you spend more time
yeah well it's well you could because
like well just just washing it yeah you
know I never had I never really spent
any time thinking about this like I
can't go on a date with you I have to
wash my hair turns out that was a legit
yeah right but now my wife is like no no
no no no no no no
do not change this this you want yeah
she wants it she wants it what is red
one red wants it too uh no I I I I like
it yeah I feel like it it feels more in
line with where I'm at yeah you know
what I mean when I was just kind of like
poking around
poking poking around you I found some
nice fan resources but there were all
these older photos of you and look
we're not these things but you know this
looks more right to me than that guy
yeah that guy I agree with that meaning
let's not let's not discredit that guy
that guy was right for them this feels
right for now in the same way that I see
myself like I see older pictures of me
yeah and I'm like I was grow ideally you
want to be growing into a truer
expression of yourself yep you've got
that you have a Thor thing and it works
and it's not just because it's in Vogue
I think this is this in fact you could
time travel with ease
yeah yeah well you could tear that tear
the labels off that shirt well yeah
button technology that came in like
1992. people don't know that and G and
these aren't what are these slacks
they're jeans oh they're like very
they're a very fine Jean yeah they're
yeah they you know they could be
confused as a pant so you we drop you in
a portal we send you back to uh ancient
Greece take my shoes off take these
Pumas off those shoes would get you
stoned I don't mean marijuana Stone I
mean they would murder you if is there a
worse way to go than just waiting for a
stone to get you just right like the
first 13 stones are just kind of like
annoying like ouchies and then like
you're like can we get this over yeah
I'm very happy to be a modern man but
God yes
are you kidding me yeah stoning was
their Netflix
there's a stoning and by the way not
even JK like there used to be all these
rules for executions my friends would my
friend Oren was just telling me about
this like there were rules the
Executioner had to do it in like one
chop like in beheadings or he'd be
beheaded so they had to like practice
there was like a lot of theater to it
and anyone who's anyone was at these
[__] oh yeah I once went to the
medieval Torture Museum in Prague
and uh
you know just the ways that people have
one of those like the Cozy coffins with
the spikes yeah the Iron Maiden for that
that's what I mean there was a the thing
that I was not anticipating excited
that's an Iron Man the thing that I was
not anticipating was the number of
um
heavy metal ways that they would lower
people onto metal spikes for whatever
you know whatever the the crime was
depending on what orifice
we'd lowered though not mortal combated
not like hit and dropped on spikes but
lowered slowly they would lower you ask
for this on one of them the lower your
ass first
that I don't care for that to a metal
Spike also the guy that suggested that
little glimpse into what he's you know
what I'm talking about like you're sorry
I listen to your album on the way down
it's fantastic oh thank you your new
album I should say uh human overboard
yeah I got nervous I was gonna get it
wrong
well you got it right that there's that
great line in the first track I believe
which is like I think that says more
about you yeah which is a great which is
great that's like good poetry good music
but like the guy that's like or we time
up to his butt and then they're like
who's in his butt and it's like Steve
everything you have is bad it doesn't
have to be the butt it doesn't have to
be the butt and then they end up using
these I mean it's not uncommon that
it the little plaque at the end would be
like and the creator of this was so and
so and this was used to kill him at the
end of his often really multiple times
that's like because think about it if
you are going to torture and murder
someone who happens to be the inventor
of a torture and murdering machine
why not use the thing that they made I
mean he's only gonna have notes if you
use something else
they're lowering face versions like guys
this would be a lot scarier if it was my
thoughts
because I can see it coming right
first you know
what a [__] [__] storm of History
like the Dark Ages in general which I
forget that like Jesus's times were more
enlightened and then there was a huge
meaning there was more technology there
was a regression and that huge
regression I totally blanked that out
that that's like a possibility that like
the fervor you'd have to get into to be
like burn the books and someone's like
no I I have like a chronic illness and
those books like help me feel better
like where were those people it's just
just Mass hysteria yeah just the stadium
and they're kind of always under the
surface waiting to that's come out again
right I mean I I do you think they're
they're they're uh where there's a
threat of uh
Gilead or is that overblown I I think
it's I think any fear is overblown yeah
if it's a if it's scary I would say that
we love it secretly love it uh enjoy it
want to spread it wanna share it any
fear not just the fear that we're gonna
burn our libraries and go back but the
with the Advent of uh the Advent with
the Advent of advent calendar season
Tiny Terrible chocolates that count down
to the Lord's birth are more popular
it's like such a stupid sentence I just
think because we have uh the internet
as soon as it's that technology that's
giving information to many people is
also streaming jiggling asses that'll
placate the uh the the library burning
people meaning if information can also
give you pornography and like a donkey
mule kicking a mule kicking a guy in the
nuts right that keeps that other stuff
like the physics or whatever it might be
that's also there is safe what I'm
saying is okay the Dark Ages wouldn't
have happened if in the back there were
some beads and a huge porno section uh
yeah right because you're saying that
the the information was too tightly
controlled and so it was easier to pull
off and now that can't really happen now
that it's totally is agrarian the word
but like everybody has it and everybody
loves it like I can't believe my dad is
texting but he is and he spells two
t-o-o no matter how it's
and like does he does he sign his
I'm still with this number here's one
that your dad signs his text oh yeah my
mom will reply to Facebook posts as if
their messages to her oh yeah so someone
will post like 13 ways to clean your
fish tank she'll be like I don't have a
fish why are you telling me this like in
the comments like and and what the last
one I saw was because someone sent me a
screen grab of it right oh yeah I'm not
[__] with that that's how I get it
yeah exactly my parents on social media
yeah yep a gentle screen if someone goes
like please stop sending like she was
like upset I don't know why you sent
this to me don't send things like this
to me again and I'm like it must be so
confusing your life must be so confusing
uh yeah man have your parents been taken
advantage of by a scammer yet because
that recently happened to his mom no
what do you call her lady died no mama
die Mama die Mama die uh I don't like
this mama die fell for the Amazon phone
call
okay Mama dies no dummy of the scams we
got what what do we got Haitian Prince
yeah it might be Nigerian prince pardon
me yeah mine was from Haiti
and I still haven't seen a return on
that 10 grand but he's back on the
throne and that's really what's
happening it's like I don't need the
money back
but he's raining once more yeah right
um there's the there's that which now we
know it's hacked but when it first
happened the reason people started
copying that was because it works oh
yeah it's a great story I have a secret
account please wire me the cash and I
can unlock it
yeah it makes a lot
it does yeah
okay uh again that reminded me of your
album that like the thrill of of seeing
someone's eyes light up you know what I
mean I thought that was really profound
and really balanced we'll get to the
record but like you're okay it's a
really balanced record thank you I was I
was hoping for that it's incredibly
balanced I I was a little not worried
but I guess I I guess I will say I was
worried I was like a little worried it
might be embittered or sort of like
but you're almost making fun of yourself
like I had these answers now I have
these I think if it came at a different
time yes in the process too early it
would have been much more bitter look we
were talking about scams let's finish
the scam yeah yeah to the record Amazon
I don't even have to get to the record
so what is Amazon called an automated
yeah this is Amazon and she you know
they tell you that your your account has
been compromised
they get the information that they need
and then they take advantage of you they
got through it without it wasn't
catastrophic like they got a credit card
uh I think they just got in the account
and started using it to Amazon yeah and
buy stuff and send it to them Quick
Queue
what
you know what I I'm that's a this is a
line of questioning that will happen
when I see them next week real quick it
was you
know it was very clear it just became
very clear I'm gonna sneeze
bless you oh yeah God I love his knees
what a joy yeah explain that do they
have that in the Dark Ages yeah they had
sneeze that's how they put out candles
they believe that if you blew out a
candle a cat died but if you sneezed it
out yeah yeah everybody wins okay uh but
it is a little or people that hold in
sneezes I I'll never understand those
people these are people that don't eat
their children's Halloween candy you
know what I mean they're they're just
not into pleasures of the flag at all
um you can also I did recently learn it
is not it is a myth that you cannot
sneeze with your eyes open that you can
you can actually can I come on mythical
this morning because I want to on camera
disprove maybe you've already done it
it's so up your alley maybe you've
already done it I can eat well over
seven Saltines without a drink of water
in a minute in a minute
I wish we had them right now I'm not
even that is that what it is it's within
a minute is that I believe uh poor Katie
Levine you can give it a goog if that's
if this is at all interesting well but
if you're gonna come on we have to we
gotta attack on multiple ones
six
six seconds I've done it before can you
drink a gallon of milk and no that's
that's even a baby cow can't drink a
gallon of milk the cow will die yeah
right like and you'll never you'll
either never poop again or you'll never
stop pooping there's no one did you ever
witness that in Middle School a gallon
yeah I saw Jason Batson try to do it I
know Jason yeah yeah yeah yeah he did
but he did it by Carton and no one knew
the math
you know nozzo was a court no one knew
how many what is a carton how much milk
is in a carton I don't know but quartz
is a funny word but you have to get
cards to get to courts and then you got
to get courts to get the gallery and
this is pretty Siri this is cut to me
last night in the grocery store my
daughter's school said bring a pound of
cheese uh because they're having like a
little cute can you imagine my daughter
right now at a little Thanksgiving table
with other children being like past the
pound of cheese uh ounces to pounds how
many ounces in a pound I would say 16
you got it
but what I love about it is no goog just
holding down that side button because I
don't [__] with hey Siri don't listen to
me when I'm not pushing your button oh
yeah I push the button not that it's not
always listening to hashtag conspiracies
but I I I push the button that's how I
like to believe it works and I go how
many ounces in a pound and it just tells
you that's that's as close as we come to
yeah Tony Stark did you get a block or
slices of cheese I'm going to tell you
something I'm not proud of it was late
the deli was closed I got pre-packaged
sliced cheese oh but I think that that's
what is standard I think that's what was
expected given the context speed agree
yeah no one expected me with that white
kind of waxy paper with the tape and
somebody wrote on it one lb yeah like
nobody yeah yeah yeah nobody runs and a
knife but if was it for the children
why is there a knife it's for the block
of cheese it's a cheese knife oh I wrote
that down dry knife that's one of your
names I was gonna randomly call you dry
knives at one point because that is
listed as one of your nickname oh in
high school yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
even remember that dry knives try knives
it's a great one
I don't know what it means and I don't
want to know yeah but uh anyway if I
came to your house I would want the deli
wrap paper but my baby got the uh
Sargento yeah yeah yeah that's sorry I
have to do this sargento.com
[Laughter]
dude you got Sargento no nobody's got it
I would love it yeah uh I wouldn't do
surgeon though ah craft yeah I'm not
doing any any uh Boar's Head you're a
Boar's Head guy nope
I don't even want to work in a vegan
agenda but anything that's Factory
farmed like anything like that is just
like oh that's just
uh you know who we did no I didn't do I
auditioned for there's some good
non-dairy cheeses we did of course
everything yeah
I can never remember which is the good
why we what we ended up choosing in fact
uh I'm this is not a plug but because of
this because I would go to the grocery
store and not remember what thing I had
liked the most yeah
and then I would have to go to the
episode and be like what did we say so
we created a website that captures all
that brilliant yeah sport.com so
anything that we've tasted and ranked
sport sport
with the Ed oh sporked yeah sporked like
a spork from KFC but then past tense
sporked I once went to KFC got a thing
of coleslaw and twisted my fingers
around it and it's those those uh Lids
are so razor sharp that it cut all four
of my fingers and I remember sitting
there being like
I know there are some people that would
complain but I don't think I'm that
person no offense to those people that
are but I was like my fingers are are
cut right why bring the 16 year old at
the cashiers like why bring the kernel
into it yeah yeah I'm gonna conjure him
up yeah just take the lesson learned
just be like yeah you know what
maybe this one's on me yeah yeah don't
not a Twist top it's not a Twist yeah
it's clearly a pop yeah don't if you
twist a pop and you get sliced it's by
Design actually that's actually on you
it's an evolutionary cue then women see
me with the slicy thingies and they go
don't breed with him but the beautiful
thing is that's the closest that we get
to torture devices in the modern era is
like accidentally opening the wrong
thing speed agree yeah I'll go so far
though as to say the music in a grocery
store is is my torture I just like when
pop music like new pop music that I
don't know I have like give me old pop
music okay I'll take it it's great I'll
even go all the way up to T Swift maybe
even Billy eilish but if there's some
new thing that is just like some guy
with a cowboy hat just showed up in LA
and they were like get over here take
your shirt off sing this song and he's
like hey have you ever seen a big red
moon but is it like wait wait catchier
than that and it stays in my head for
eternity and I'm like man I'm just here
for Sargento sargento.com weird I'm so
sorry but like hashtag Factory
to the website I that's that's torturous
to me what can't you stand
anything getting your goat these days
you do look like you own a goat uh I
would I would I would love a goat
um I'd drink my own goat's milk like I
don't think milk is like inherently
disgusting or anything
but you don't drink milk but if you if
it was uh on your farm yeah yeah for
sure yeah that's like a
that's something that's changed okay
like if I see the chickens laying the
eggs and they're running around you can
make the connection I'm just like yeah
this thing seems better for me
uh you know and I you know I uh he's
getting your goat I'm sure that it is
but I'm probably repressing it
nothing annoys you oh no lots of things
yeah lots of things annoying like I'm
saying pop music that's too catchy like
I'll get follow me you know yeah I'm I'm
in the same boat there I I don't I'm not
I'm not on that train no that's not my
that's not my music what it what really
if I wanted to get your goat or what in
life still gets under your skin no
matter what
um
well how loud of a chewer are you that's
a great question
look I'm gonna say something
everyone thinks they're a good driver
okay everyone thinks they're the right
level of sound when chewing everyone
and speaking I was recently in a room
with a loud talker
yeah I'm not trying to take us off
chewing this woman didn't know she was
loud but she was like I'm like we're in
a we're in a small room
everyone can hear you fine
but chewing my father is a very loud
chewer I'll give you that also he makes
this sound when he cuts his meat he goes
every every time there's nothing yeah
I'm trying you know I'm trying to not
that I because link is a loud sure
that's why oh is he yeah yeah and so
this is he just dropped I just watched
him go down like nine pegs in my mind
well but it's like we chew on the
internet for a living yes and they're in
any and it's so so loud that I think I
probably have adjusted somewhat because
I don't think about it as much anymore
you know actually something that really
got me my wife and I got into an
argument last night so Jesse and and my
son Shepard and I were going to Elton
John at Dodger Stadium sure okay last
last tour yep uh we're all big fans and
Evie Shepherd loves old school music has
always been a oh he loves Elton yes so
you know when you pull up the the
like the seek geek digital ticket it
says 8 P.M so I'm late okay well now
concert says 8 P.M you get there like
right around 8 P.M right
for sure yeah but unless you want to see
the opening act tune yeah you know what
I mean yeah but that's not how Elton
Works in fact as we're driving there and
I'm like man the traffic is a lot worse
like everybody's going to see Elton John
like I've been to a Dodgers baseball
game and apparently that's not that
popular yeah but Elton John Sells out
the entire place and then there's
everybody on the field so the traffic is
the next Baseball fans better drivers
than Elton John family okay that's
probably also a factor these guys are
having dodged right well so I start
realizing that we're going to be there
like eight
30. that was also a bet by the way I
don't really believe that 8 30 yes and
Jesse
brings up on the phone and it says oh uh
Elton starts promptly at 8 pm he is
known for starting on time and there
isn't an opening act
I mean
it's so not rock and roll that it became
rock and roll yeah and I was like I
should have known this that Elton John
starts on time yeah and now that that's
not the pet peeve the pet peeve I'm
getting to is that my wife did not get
as mad as me
okay and this I wanted to be mirrored
yes and and this is something that I've
discovered about myself if we are
running late to something if we might
miss a flight
she remains so calm
and it annoys me that she is calm I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna join you in
this thought system and say something
that I don't even necessarily agree with
but out of love okay for your belief
here and I've been there I'm going to
say it's disloyal
that's what it feels like like let's
call it what it is and that's what I
told her last night I said I just want
you to get under this rock with me yeah
yeah
and she was like but you're not changing
anything that's great we're not changing
anything I was like but you could find a
you could be you could find a parking
deck
you know I'm like I I'm just coming up
with things you know we ended up parking
like a mile away from Dodger Stadium and
walking and we got there faster than if
we had continued on in really yeah and
Elton plays for three hours so you got
enough help yeah yeah that was actually
that was a blessing in disguise yeah
right yeah because two and a half was
plenty there is
I don't even want to be [__] for
three hours
[Laughter]
do you know what I mean yeah two and a
half in you're like yeah all right maybe
12 something
soft minute like I want to move on to
challenges yeah yeah I would like to try
it once did you hear Benny in the jet uh
no we Benny and the Jess was playing as
we got into earshot of the stadium
and then he goes into you know
I said huge fans let me qualify that I
already didn't believe you but keep
going I am
a huge fan of the Elton songs that
you're probably a huge fan of you know
what I mean oh yeah and I think that
there are
nine of those you know what I'm saying
and nine times three I'm not here to do
math but I think it's about half an hour
and then there is a lot there's a lot
that I've that I haven't heard yeah um
that is you know you get into playing a
certain type of music when you're
playing live yeah because you get a
reaction from people yeah yeah and I
like the soulful
slower
Elton stuff maybe they'll get we get a
little bit funky at times but when the
BPM gets
yeah I don't know what it would be maybe
one 120 plus yeah yeah I'm I'm losing
interest and the visuals
you know I've never seen it I've never
seen a I've never been to a concert this
big like yeah the screens are so giant
it's Dodger Stadium of course and
somebody Elton or someone
Elton adjacent has made choices about
what we're gonna put on the screens yeah
and so he's got the song about goodbye
Norma Jean which is a good song about
saying goodbye to Marilyn Monroe it's in
the top nine he has a lot of goodbye
songs yes
their visual that plays the whole time
during this song someone died call Elton
it wasn't over apparently is a video of
a Marilyn Monroe look alike that takes
you like what is this karaoke it takes
you
it took me
15 seconds to figure out it was a
look-alike it took the older couple next
to me
four minutes like we're almost done with
a song and they went that's not her and
I was like this is not I mean this is
how do we have this footage of her in a
bathtub drinking wine
in this high-res and then I was like the
res alone yeah yeah yeah giveaway it's
like she's doing things and then she's
upset and I was like what's this and
then I'm like and it doesn't even like
really it looks like a Hollywood
Boulevard Marilyn Monroe if you think
they didn't find that woman in front of
man's Chinese Theater Elton was running
late to the show he's like we need the
footage yeah yeah and she shows full nip
she's jumping on a bed and they both pop
out and this is just
on the screen at an Elton John show give
him what they want yeah give him the
fake merry nips
your son well let's put it what it
really is yeah your son has full access
to whatever nips he wants to see you and
I would have been like
because I would have been like don't let
anyone know how much that meant to me
yeah in fact little fun fact
one of Marilyn Monroe was the first
obviously the first Playboy centerfold
did you know I did not know that yeah so
she you can find nudies Marilyn Monroe
okay and one time I was on a trip with
my friend Nick and they had a Life
magazine and in the Life Magazine there
was a recreation of that centerfold but
it was like this big that's how horny
you are it only it doesn't take much man
a postage stamp oh so the nips are like
the size of what like the dots on snow
caps
I can't believe I found it right away
tiny little pralines
non-perels that's what it is yes
I don't know what a perel is but if this
is this is not well yeah I don't want to
see a parallel
um another Elton question for you
I know a lot if he well this is just
you're gonna have to use your
imagination if he played Benny and the
Jets in the stadium where the New York
Jets play hmm
how much louder is the crowd like are
they
like the Orioles where the Orioles play
when they sing the national anthem and
they get to oh say they all yell oh
because it's Orioles so here's Elton
John playing Benny and the Jets where
the Jets play and I'm gonna ask you a
hard question what percentage of the
crowd thinks the song is it I think at
that point they're like they're about
they're like whoa is this about the Jets
yes that's it yeah I'll accept the guy
that goes is this about the Jets by the
way same guy that goes is that Marilyn
Monroe did I just see Marilyn Monroe's
praline nips
what do you think uh I actually have
anecdotal evidence from last night to
help with this because wait this was
last night yeah yeah I'm still mad I'm
mad for you uh yeah I still I'm still
feeling it yeah yeah yeah it's emanating
the the the famous uh you know Dodger
Stadium show that he did in the 70s or
80s or whatever
where he's in the Dodgers uniform I
don't know this but okay yeah is it
sparkly uh yes yeah and uh you know
there were many many people in this
outfit in the crowd first of all
and I was like is he going Elton uh he's
75 I think so basically he's not really
fitting into uh is he only 75 yeah I
would have thought I would have said 85.
I would have said 80 plus 80 plus until
somebody said 75 and then he said 75
from stage but a baseball uniform would
not be flattering so he has he wore a
baseball robe
that's dead okay I'm full of death a
baseball like a bathrobe oh yeah
totally sequent in an LA hat fluffy here
yeah oh yeah that's in case he nods off
yeah pops right back up in the back
hello but uh robe because you don't want
to look like Babe Ruth
yeah you look like Lou gehrer he
definitely thought about that even Babe
Ruth in a time when men
had to give no consideration even he was
like I sort of look like one of those
dummies that you punched and I come
right back yeah right like a like a
peanut shape yeah buy me some peanuts
and Cracker Jack that point to babe for
the first part yeah the expectations
were a little bit different yeah for a
75 year old musician yeah we don't
you're playing but that's our
expectation is that you're playing and
you're exceeding it if you're still
playing it and you and he sounds great
XXX but
when they showed they actually cut to a
close-up of the Dodgers logo like a
camera
locked in on the Dodgers logo at some
point on his robe no on just the stadium
okay at a point in the shed together at
a point in the song because there is no
Dodgers song yeah there's no Benny in
the Dodgers that doesn't happen so I
guess they just knew that they wanted to
do it at some point and when they cut to
that
more than a smattering of Applause good
nuts yeah so imagine if he was singing
Benny and the Dodgers
yeah it would be yeah people lose their
minds absolutely I went and saw
Radiohead once I've seen look
I don't know if you can tell by my
neutral colors I've seen Radiohead yeah
and one of the songs uh Thomas York was
playing the piano and so huge screens
like you're saying and the camera was
just zoomed in on what I can only call
with respect his goofy eye by goofy I
don't mean ugly I'm just saying the one
that's kind of a little bit more
personality is seeing other things
that's the Loyalty you want from your
wife yeah right and you join me in the
movie Tom
yeah
friend I well I
look I I've been known to have the you
know depending on the picture yeah it's
you can get a goofy I think at some
point it started fixing itself because
it never got any professional help but
there was like a period in my 20s
pressure of the internet a period in my
20s where one eye would be wondering a
little bit in a in a picture here or
there you had a Tom York yeah now you're
Tom Brady
but I mean like that I thought was um I
just loved it actually I was like
they're zooming in on the thing that you
could call a wound yeah I'm just saying
Little Tommy York
at all I'm assuming he went to Oxford
they all go to that's safe question mark
uh yeah they're all very well educated
that's all I know incredibly well
educated this is the benefit of being
mildly caffeinated
we're so caffeinated we need to like
second screen our education we need like
a video they're just sipping tea and
they can listen to Alexa on Churchill so
anyway he's at Oxford that is the the if
you're doing a rap battle against Tom
York the first thing you notice one he
looks a little like Chris gethard too so
you're like guthard heathard method
that I I'm Gonna Save that eye for the
clothes oh yeah or the open and the
clothes yeah yeah you tease it yeah yeah
you tease that you tease it I'm Gonna
Save Your Eye till the end
this is your first line oh God what did
that old LT close with and more
importantly because it says more about
you did you leave before the last song I
did not wow uh and this is a page that
my wife and I are both on which is the
which my parents are not on okay we've
never been on who wants to leave in your
parents relationship uh both of them oh
they they and not just concerts but any
event including something that's just at
your home they'll leave their own home
so we gotta we gotta get going we got
your your daddy's gotta we've gotta get
up tomorrow like it's like there's the
reasons don't make sense but they're out
right you know but we both you're in a
different time zone it's 4 P.M dab
right Elton John is in our living room
but we Jesse doesn't like to fight the
the traffic we want we wanted because we
were late we wanted to go get some merch
you know so we were here did they have a
shirt that says I was late to the Elton
John no but they did have one that says
the [__] is back and that's the one
that I bought
great
um which is the slogan for aliens three
yeah
I know legitimately this is a bitch's
back
so we're the same age we basically we we
hung around for a little bit but uh he
closed with because it is the farewell
tour and is the farewell Yellow Brick
Road he closes with yellow brick road or
is he just not [__] it is an encore
which uh it's so it's so interesting to
see somebody who has done an act
so many times in fact he he begins
talking at one point he's like this is
my 101st show in Los Angeles wow that
means like 101 towards basically
yeah and he's like in my fifth time at
Dodger Stadium
and he has all the things that he does
that you know that I'm sure you know
they've all been sort of like toned down
as he's gotten older but the fake
pointing to the people in the you know
uh uh but he somebody told me David
Copperfield someone worked for David
Copperfield and they know to mute his
mic in between lines so he'll be like
everyone knows nothing can penetrate
titanium and then they'll cut his mic
and he can turn to his assistant and go
chicken Caesar like you can order his
lunch like mad respect yes okay that's
the thing that I was thinking was how
much of a system this is and it's very
it's just fascinating to see it unfold
exactly that you know they get it
completely down do you think he even
gets like an adrenaline right he must
from doing it but do you think he's
nervous I bet he's not even nervous I
don't think you do Dodger Stadium but
listen they're having a great time the
guy he has three drummers of course I
wasn't prepared to talk this much about
Elton but I'm glad that you're humoring
me human this is what enraptured looks
like
and the main guy has been in the band
well the way Elton put it in and out of
the band
since 1969.
the main guy the guy who's like the in
the drum set that is the tallest and the
highest oh so you get upgraded like a
like a point yeah there's levels yeah
yeah it's like a Podium and he's the
gold medal drummer and he's been in and
out
since 1969 and he's having the best time
there's a place there's a part in the
concert where he talks about all the
band mates that have died and then he
sings it takes 45 minutes he sings
whatever one of his songs about people
being dead you were right he sings that
song Whatever that one is
Candle in the Wind yeah uh no because
that's the
that's gotta learn more of it isn't it
you said goodbye you Norma Jean or
whatever well oh yeah you lived your
life like a Candle in the Wind that's
right yeah but there's another there's
another dead person song and he covers
like four people in one song at DPS but
but then he goes to the guys playing
with him and they're all old yeah and
they're all having the time of their
lives like I just can't I mean I'm
thinking at a certain age you need a
show at Dodger Stadium to anime yeah
backstage and then you're like
hello yeah man I mean I think that you
know obviously you have experienced the
thrill of being in front of a crowd in
like an electric crowd but I think that
there's no more electric crowd than for
a musician right I was just gonna say
Gabriel Iglesias did this podcast not
long ago shortly before that he had done
Dodger Stadium two nights um
obviously by the way to broaden this not
just to Gabe but Madison Square Garden
all of these like sort of ego sets by
the way ego I don't mean like it was
necessarily Gabe or aziz's ego that did
it necessarily but to me I'm like
like first of all I will concede no
one's asking me to do those like it
would be really funny to sell 700
tickets at Dodger Stadium and just
perform for just behind the the plate
there's no one's that there's everyone's
on the field we oh yeah everybody
's down here
full
I would say that chaotic it doesn't even
matter if I'm talking eating belching
not listening energy that unlocked in
energy which it doesn't matter how well
you're doing yeah at any given time
there's a thousand people not listening
and talking and going to the bathroom or
whatever or buying merch is exactly why
I got into comedy is to never have the
feeling of like God it's like I'm
talking to Dodger Stadium here because
that's the feeling I felt when I was a
kid and it made me feel small and
significantly scared so I want to be a
size that's locked in I want them to
know that I'm there in fact I would
argue that the joke isn't even the joke
the joke is that I'm there with them
co-creating the joke right but if
they're just a mass
I'm like what is this a squid a Giants
yeah it was really hitting me you know
because I mean probably but for music
yeah the the biggest crowd that link and
I have ever
played for is probably like 5 000 at
dorton whatever dorton arena in North
Carolina holds at the State Fair wow
North Carolina that's great yeah but but
usually it's like you know uh uh a
thousand fifteen hundred something like
that and those crowds can be like super
Electric
but yeah there's a connection but like
that's the thing that I was saying I was
like there's just no you said it's so
weird like what is happening here that
this is what he has to do yeah because
of how many people want to see him yeah
but that's true I suppose I will have an
interesting conversation with uh with a
with someone after uh you know I haven't
played I've played the music for the
from the album live one time I played it
at our mythicon which is our fan
conference that we did in uh Austin so
fun and before that I did one song in a
Waylon Jennings tribute set from his son
Shooter Jennings who is a friend
um the story is I was asking shooter for
tickets to a festival in Redondo Beach
where this was going to be featured and
two days before the festival and he said
you want to play a song and of course I
said yes even though I had nothing
prepared just because you can't say no
to that yeah but that was a bit I don't
know I couldn't it was one of those it
was a festival so you couldn't really
see the end it was dark it was was at
night you couldn't really see the end of
the crowd
but like getting up there with a band
which is not something I typically do
it's just me and a guitar usually or me
and Link and Link is playing like a
recorder or a harmonica sure but getting
up there with a band and having this
electric crowd
I was like man this is so
such a high oh I bet I was talking to
somebody about that they're like yeah
that's why I mean first of all comedians
obviously substance abuse is a huge
issue in the comedian Community but the
musicians
once you experience that and the bigger
you are and the and and the more intense
the connection and the feeling from that
crowd has been you're just chasing that
you're going to keep chasing it and the
only way to get it without yeah a
performance is Right some sort of
substance yeah you have two choices when
it's done I think the younger people
maybe even into the older people want to
like I remember Steven Tyler eats cream
puffs after his Aerosmith shows he goes
back and eats like Gourmet cream puffs I
don't remember where I saw this but he
was like it used to be and then he just
went like your mind doing cocaine and I
was like so that's maintained could have
been Flonase you don't know it could
have been Flonase yeah it could have
been Mucinex sorry I have to do this
mucinex.com weird they are they factory
farm their ingredients I'm just kidding
um so uh snorting the cocaine that's
maintained I know a lot of comedians
that would try to maintain booze can go
both ways bring you down and also kind
of help question mark maintain but uh I
I know what you mean like when I would
see like Tom Petty or whatever which I'm
glad I did before it was one of his last
shows I was like oh yeah this is the
only way to get this feeling like I I
bet even cocaine even I look nobody
tried this but like even heroin I bet is
a different sensation for sure than that
locked in this I bet it even transcends
affirmation like Elton John isn't going
like they really liked it like I don't
think he's thinking that no if he could
do anything because he comes in on a
foundation of everything that you've
ever experienced about him and the way
that he has made you feel yeah and
nothing can nothing can screw that up no
you know you're absolutely right no
one's listening to a comedy record when
they lose their virginity
and if they are that's so weird it was
accidental approved right yeah like the
the spotify's shuffling and it just
plays me being like what's up with old
refrigerators killing kids it was too
late you've already started coming
and you did this for three hours
we're just the folding in a bit yeah
it's got to be it's got to be one of the
best highs in the world I've thought
about this this feels like a mythical
question for you if you could be amazing
at any sport what would you be like the
best in the world at any sport like you
are the king the best that's ever lived
which sport
wow
don't forget boxing by the way people
forget how big a deal Mike Tyson was or
Muhammad Ali and this is a great
question you can knock out anybody the
other thing that's great about and I'm
going to Prime you a little bit the
other thing that's great about boxing I
don't think you're going to pick boxing
is it's you football you kind of look
like a robot like you're you're you're
in uniform that conceals you which is
why basketball Stars will always be
bigger than football stuff yeah yeah
yeah because they're just out there kind
of in a tank or like tennis tennis hey
dude it's just me
would be famous at all if you had to
wear a Daft Punk Helmet like that's just
how we play tennis uh wow I have to
think about this in the context of
um my
what you what you probably experience
which is uh what I would call
we're semi-famous right yeah sure so
you're gonna you're gonna you don't even
say that bad I think semi-famous is
where you want to be you think you want
to be Jared Leto no that's what I'm
saying I think Jared Leto can go to a
Target I go to Target nobody exactly for
a second so I go and I go to the grocery
store by myself yeah I shop for what I
want you want a security detail and
there might be a person that comes up
but I can do that don't get me started
on semi-famous and so I think that being
really great at the best ever at
something I think I don't want to lose
what I have so I think it would probably
be like darts
because I would be amazing like I feel
like I was trying to like out mythical
you
you just proved why you're the king of
like tests strategy like trivia like you
just nailed that so hard and I'll never
forget where I was right here when you
said darts yeah and think about it you'd
be good at it until your dying day
unless you got oh yeah arm cancer or
something but you you The elusive arm
care yeah you're right sure you could do
that until you're old everyone would
always appreciate it and be like hey I'm
gonna say by the way it's the best he's
the best Dart guy in the world I'm gonna
throw something especially away because
you won and I'm the grantor of this
magical ability even if you lost your
arm God forbid you lose your arm you can
do it with your other arm even if you
lose both arms you can do it with your
feet no matter what you're the best you
can get a dart in there yeah you could
bite one and swing it with your teeth
yeah it's going in that Redstone yeah
you wouldn't think but he is the best in
the world and I'm actually gonna throw
this at you you missed just enough to
keep it interesting oh yeah yeah because
it can't just be both nobody wants to
see it you think you want to see a guy
throwing Bull's eyes every once in a
while we see just a little Humanity yeah
it pings off the metal Circle that's
around the red Center you want that Ted
lasso scene if I don't know if you saw
that but the dart scene I also don't
remember it I I'm impressed I just
remember I just remember that he Against
All Odds he wins boiler yeah
they let Ted win that's that show he
keeps getting kicked in the nuts nothing
ever gets better right yeah right I'm
thinking of the movie Babel
I often confused the movie Bell yeah
yeah it's easy yeah common mistake
that's a very I mean Google it Pages
upon pages of people confusing the movie
Babel
um all right let's talk about the record
and okay let's actually do this because
we're at the mid-roll we'll do a
mid-roll yes in the biz and when we come
back don't don't don't
be a YouTube cliche and drop off
analytics I've been told I don't check
but that people sometimes drop off in
the middle because we want to talk about
this great record which is called human
overboard I think it's an it's special
and and it has a lot to say and you're
not going to want to miss it and I'm
going to ask you if you've ever died
ever seen a ghost in a UFO or anything
you can't explain so there's lots of fun
in literally two minutes
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at mindbloom you just need to take
better care of yourself is not a
response to mental health struggles and
you know that you live with it sometimes
you need something more to achieve a
real and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's
time we check out a guided ketamine
Therapy Program from mind Bloom mind
Bloom is the leader in at-home ketamine
therapy offering a combination of
science-backed medicines with clinician
and guide support for people looking to
improve their mental health and
well-being mind Bloom connects patients
to licensed psychiatric clinicians to
help them achieve better outcomes with
lower costs greater convenience and an
artfully crafted experience to begin
take mind Bloom's online assessment and
schedule a video consult with a licensed
clinician to determine if mind Bloom is
right for you if approved you'll discuss
your health history and goals for mental
health treatment with your clinician to
tailor your mind Bloom regimen mind
Bloom will send you a kit in the mail
complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only two
sessions 87 percent of Mind Bloom
clients reported improvements in
depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety it is time to
enter the next chapter in mental health
and well-being and let mind Bloom guide
you right now mind Bloom is offering
weirdos our listeners one hundred
dollars off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com
ymiw like you made it weird ymi-w and
use promo code ymiw at checkout go to
mindbloom.com ymiw promo code ymiw for a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program today that's
mindbloom.com ymiw promo code y m i w
I had so many friends have their lives
transformed by that therapy I'm so happy
to have mind Bloom on board also display
is a new sponsor I'm super excited I
even have one if you're watching this on
the video
this is a display look at that
look at this
you can hear it you have a poster you
can hear displate is a one-of-a-kind
metal poster designed to capture your
unique passion so if your unique passion
is me you can get this PD as my homeboy
display it's available now display
created a 21st century canvas that's
sturdy magnet mounted which is super
cool and durable enough to withstand a
lifetime of intense staring and frankly
moving we just moved so many of our
posters did not make it this blade is
here to save the day and not only that
it's such a it's a more immortal and
like permanent and substantial way to
get your passions up on the wall but
staring is only half the fun you can
customize collect and rearrange them at
will display display has both branded
and artistic artwork they have over one
million designs available for everyone
including official designs from Brands
like Marvel DC Star Wars net Flex NASA
South Park plenty of games and movies
everybody can find something for
themselves including if you're a fan of
my work I just uploaded a bunch of
display designs that you can check out
including
Wikipedia is my homeboy damsels do it
their damn selves uh give to Little
Caesar what is Little Caesars a lot of
our best t-shirts uh not feeling it
chicken of course not feeling it chicken
is now perfectly immortalized in the
medium they were intended to be
something substantial and beautiful and
high quality each product is a high
quality design printed on metal in
Europe and hand signed by their master
of production display
create a unique safe magnet mounted
system that only takes 20 seconds that
means no need for drilling your walls
all you need to do is wipe your wall
with a cleaning wipe stick a protective
Leaf Place a magnet and put the display
on your wall it really does take 20
seconds it's that easy display delivers
its products worldwide in only four to
five business days I can attest to that
as these just derived and I just ordered
them it is a perfect alternative for
standard paper posters that often get
damaged facts and it doesn't leave marks
on the wall facts they are also
eco-friendly for every design sold they
are planting one tree so right now this
blade is having the biggest discount
ever for buying once two designs you get
35 off for buying three to four you get
39 off if you buy five or more displays
you will get 44 off that's almost half
price again just to take a look they are
beautiful they are fun and you can get
up to 44 off if you order five or more
so use the link in the description or go
to
display.com slash Pete Holmes that's
d-i-s-p-l-a-t-e.com slash Pete homes and
use code weird at checkout displayed
collect your passions and last but not
least think your job stinks
just wait until you hear what it was
like to be a funeral clown that's right
long before all of human knowledge was
in your pocket some people had some very
bizarre professions luckily you don't
have to be a sin eater or Barber surgeon
yikes now but you will find out what
it's like to get surgery with a shave
with wondry's new podcast this job is
history hosted by my pal Chris Parnell
from SNL and Rick and Morty and also
this podcast he was a great guest
steeped in factual history this
brilliantly funny podcast delves into
the quirking Absurd jobs from the past
with hilarious interviews that are
infused with fascinatingly true Easter
eggs so come and get weird with each
week as improv comedians from
Groundlings and UCB meaning some of the
best improvisers in the world act out
their old-fashioned gig from another
time you'll be glad your guidance
counselor didn't recommend any of these
jobs nobody funnier than Chris and I'm
honestly nothing more interesting than
strange strange jobs I'm gotta check out
the funeral funeral clown episode and I
could listen to Chris Barnell talk about
anything this just happens to be one of
the most interesting topics for a
podcast I've ever heard of so definitely
clock in and follow this job as history
on Amazon music Apple podcast or listen
early and AD free by joining wondry Plus
in the onedry app check out this job is
history alright everybody let's get back
to Rhett McLaughlin
okay we're back
going back to what I was saying about
the record yeah
and I let's start with this
um
it is possible and as I said if I'm
being honest I was worried that I was
going to put it on and it was going to
be this like
you know
what I did if I had written a record
when I first started to deconstruct my
faith it would have been a little
you really think a snake told a lady eat
an apple come on get real get real get
real get real wait this is good
yes you know and so much deconstruction
or really deconstruction such a Negative
term
um reconstruction or or beautiful
examination can be done from this place
of bitterness but you seem to have
waited the right amount of time I want
to know what you think is the right
amount of time where again I might be
getting the lyrics wrong but it seemed
like you were like I had the truth
before and now I have this truth and
like let's be real guys like in both of
those experiences I think I'm right so I
could be wrong again almost yes okay
tell me everything yeah so you know
there's not a lot of examples of
somebody making this decision to do an
album that is so centered around the
subject matter
um but one that is out there is David
bazan So curse curse your branches I
think it was like you know 2008 2009
and totally different genre of music but
it was kind of a pivotal
I discovered it late like probably 2014
2015 after I'd basically gone through
my deconstruction
but I just related so I was like oh
somebody's sort of singing this anthem
for this stuff that that I've been
through that reached me at a time yes
when I really needed it right
and shout out to bazan and it's great
but scared Katie
but it is more bitter uh buddy I I would
say this to David who I consider a
friend I agree with you and and in fact
when I riffed that sort of like the
Garden of Eden isn't literal there's
there's Garden of Eden isn't literal uh
lyrics in that album and it's an
incredible song and it it's also a great
song but you know how I sing it I go
it's hard to read the Bible literally
because he goes it's hard to be a decent
human being yes yes I say it's hard to
read but I mean that that's dismissive
of something to be clear that record
means a lot to me but it there was a
time when it meant a lot and what I was
exactly what and I was thinking of it I
was like okay
he did that record at that time which is
like one of the only examples I can
point to is like he's in that state he
was in that stage he wrote that and I
was you know 2013 or so is when I
stopped calling myself a Christian so
we're almost coming up on 10 years but I
did not process a lot of it and I
definitely didn't process it publicly
link and I weren't even talking about it
you know when we did the podcast last
time we were about to go public with our
deconstruction yeah so we there was
hints that you know which you know that
kind of kept us from really being able
to just like sitting here in there
within the frequency that people emit
when they're kind of like
it's almost like I want to kiss you I
just have to wait for my divorce to be
fine and you know what I I believe that
uh I don't remember where we were at in
our decision to make that choice to to
go public with our deconstruction
stories but it was that Dynamic that we
were experiencing on your podcast yeah
that was a dynamic that we just we hate
it couldn't bear it anymore it was just
like we're we we get so personal and so
vulnerable about so many things and
there's this giant thing that we avoid
yeah it's like a huge it's like six
sevenths of the pizza yeah right you
can't talk about it yeah I'll happily
talk about my favorite deodorant you
know right by the way a lot of people
can relate I'm not even I'm not putting
you down just yeah and so that was you
know so thank you for uh ushering that
along I I didn't even mind I just I
remember a feeling of blue balls for all
of us yeah yeah yeah yeah because we
were kind of like because we were like
yeah man we're gonna you know we're
gonna probably do it on our podcast so
after doing that
um you know and I've been I've been in
therapy I guess for five five or six
five years now and one of the things
that I started doing was I I just
started writing link and I have written
comedy songs together for years the
recorder yes with the recorder very
often hard to write an Earnest song it
really you know if you just want to
really clue everyone in that this is
supposed to be funny just put a recorder
in but so but I'd never really written
anything serious and since since our
high school Christian band days you know
the wax paper dogs back in the mid 90s
second reference to wax paper back to
the deli we'll find a third uh
uh so but I wrote I wrote the first song
that I wrote is the last song in the
album and again I was just writing these
songs for myself recording them in like
a voice memo yeah and then I would talk
to my therapist about him and he and one
of the things he's been working on with
me was essentially just my tendency to
take everything to the Head take
everything to rationalization
intellectualize everything on the record
yeah about rationalization yeah so very
it is funny I want to say real real
quick we won't forget where we are the
humor is really dialed in oh thanks and
really
um
you know how you can overdo parmesan
cheese yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like the
most overdoable cheese right yeah uh
it's just right a little sharp a little
sharp keeps me interested not that you
have to keep me interested I'm just
saying like I noticed that the humor was
there yeah like the perfect use of [__]
in the in the give a damn I was like
that's right and it should be the third
song you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
it's correct it's like yeah it's well
made it's well made
um and so I that last song was which is
the most honest song which is where it
leaves you know unresolved chord
unresolved lyric of like maybe we'll
meet again like I'm leaving myself open
to that that was where I was at I wrote
that song in 2019 I told my therapist
about it and he was like you seem to be
much more vulnerable and honest with
yourself and this process and actually
you can process a feeling about
something through your music so you
should you should keep doing that what's
great if for no other reason than for
your own your therapist is Jimmy Iovine
yeah exactly we have something in here
I feel like there's mixed motive Series
yeah so none of that was it wasn't
intended to be an album from the
beginning it was intended to be this
like I don't know what I'll do with this
how glorious who knows what I don't have
to I'm backing a tour I don't have any
time for this let me get another
nickname Taylor
I was on the list of nicknames Taylor is
there anything worse than comedy written
for fame or music written to to like
sell or to be a wrecker like like Tom
Petty again Tom Petty coming up he said
that he was just playing around and he
wrote wild he sang wildflowers the first
time he recorded it all the way through
just done that's sort of like Earnest
channeling whether it's something Divine
we can play with that if we want but
like it's just coming straight from you
and if there's anything that fellas like
us meaning when I say show body I don't
mean bad I mean like we've done our part
to seize the Limelight we wanted it and
we did it
I don't know if there's another way for
you to make this album yeah like you
would have had to be like voice memos
and and your therapist being like I
think you're processing so it came from
a need compliment alert I think you can
feel that in the music like this wasn't
just
follow me
what's with my chip on Uncle Kracker but
like Uncle Kracker was trying to write a
hit single yes
and he succeeded he also succeeded but
like well I think one of the things that
helped I don't know why I'm going on is
not only the I mean the genre I mean
obviously I'm not I'm doing
country which is not you're not going to
get to the top of the pop charts and
then if the subject matter is something
that's inherently
divisive
um because that's that's what we'll talk
about that is just the the sort of the
Christian response did one that was
great
um similar have you heard of seven yes
yeah so I haven't connected with similar
but
enough of fans of James and the shame
stuff have pointed uh to somewhere yeah
yeah similar is great yes they are
there's a connection yeah and so uh and
there's more people doing deconstruction
themed stuff now that's by the way in
case just to be real clear it sounded
like I was putting down bazan I don't
think you have similar or you like that
tradition without someone doing the
wrong oh yeah like this is really what
it feels like when you feel like the
wool's been pulled over well and I I
think that there's
I think there's a I mean I think he did
Bitter and as in as poetic yes as a way
possibly could it's valid yeah it's a
part of it in fact and there's some
better there's some bitter songs on my
album for sure uh well I'm agreeing
because you wrote it and I'm like you if
you say so I mean I
I was you know
one of the things I talk about a lot is
how the the old me the conservative
Evangelical missionary Rhett who looked
at everything so suspiciously and
everyone so suspiciously everyone Geico
commercial yeah exactly
all right I just got in my roast mode I
don't know write that on the list
[Music]
um
so but that guy he's never going to
leave my brain yeah right and so I A lot
of times I'm writing something I'm
saying something something on our
podcast if we get into something that's
more controversial you do a taste test
for religion there's like oh that yeah
exactly for crack for wafers that's a
great idea what's the best comedian
wafer
I know my breath you know what my church
did broken up Saltines baby maybe that's
where I learned it had a high tolerance
because of that Feast on the body of
Christ in under a minute
our church upgraded to real bread at
some point the real bread church that's
how you knew you were in like
Connecticut you know what I mean when
they like break some from this low well
this was not denominational North
Carolina because we all broke off from a
Baptist Church that did like the
baptist.com Wafers you know what I'm
saying like the Baptist manual there's
the manual and then we were like we're
not going to do those so let's do the
real bread but like let's it's a power
move you're like it's like uh the Last
Crusade it's like he was a carpenter I'd
have like a normal cup and like it was a
simple type that have like normal bread
but like glaze a little egg wash on it
you're right but just like over time but
you want it to look like a regular bread
not you didn't have crackers right yeah
he didn't want a cracker technology
um they had Uncle Kracker but that guy
because he never leaves I filter so much
through what what would his knee-jerk
reaction to what I'm saying to it yeah
and how can I head it off at the past so
I don't know if I'm not judged which is
one of the reasons that the the album is
structured in the way that it is in that
you talk about that flash of rationality
that that second song is early yeah in
the album because thematically I'm just
trying to remind people that like this
isn't I don't think that I've figured
this stuff out this isn't some was there
anything worse you know this isn't the
hey this is where I I figured it out and
this is my you know Treatise on
spiritual things but this is more like
this is a person who is in the middle of
a process yeah and there's some songs
that have come out of that process but
I've noticed that even just this past
week because I'm uh I just released the
the album as a pre-order on vinyl so I'm
trying to kind of stir up a little
social media interest there so people
will know about it yeah edit that out
and so
and so I just did an acoustic version of
the
um uh only thing which is the only thing
I'm certain of is that I ain't certain
about much that song
which doesn't seem particularly like uh
like aggressive but the Christian
responses in the comments are very much
it's clear that they feel attacked by
that song me saying that I'm not certain
about what I believe that I was in the
past and I'm not now is somehow an
attack on them and that's I realize the
the old rat in me spoke up and said well
you know the reason that they are doing
that is because
every single thing you did
as a conservative Evangelical Christian
was designed to change people's mind and
to like every interaction every
conversation was supposed to be
influential for Christ it was you were
supposed to change someone's mind so I
think they assumed that certainty was
the only reason that I'm doing this is
because I want to actively change
people's minds I want people to not be
Christians anymore I'm coming after them
right whereas I'm just throwing
something out into this big sea of
thoughts and perspectives that I don't
think any of us have a really firm grasp
on but when you think that no you do I
do have a firm grasp on it and I'm the
one who's right anyone else who says
something different they must be coming
from the same place and I'm just like
hey I'm not coming from that place
anymore that's really I'm not trying I'm
not trying to
now if I am trying to change your mind
it's when my ego it's what tole talks
about is like when you when you when
you're arguing and you
remove the elements of the argument that
are you just
Defending Your Ego and trying to win you
start arguing about a lot less stuff
that's right right you might defend
something you might be exercising that
compassion you're recognizing that like
why it's also sounds like forgiveness to
me it's like why if I used to think that
when you're talking you're trying to win
them over for for Jesus of course you're
still doing that but you're doing it for
the other side now yeah I'm on the other
team it's like when I got divorced uh
I remember married people I noticed
decidedly married people didn't want to
talk to me because married people often
like are proponents for marriage and
commitment so it stands to reason that a
divorced person is sort of dangerous
because they might be like you know what
Rhett I thought I would hate it but I
love it yeah like it's like married men
especially like really didn't want to
talk to me
um because they were afraid that I might
sell them something because we used to
be in the religion of of marriage and
monogamy by the way I'm I'm married and
I love it and I'm monogamous and all of
that but I'm just saying similar why
wouldn't you then start proselytizing
yours so you were careful to not
I mean it's it the 10 years-ness is
really coming through in the art and I'm
really glad just for you I guess I'm
glad it's maybe the wrong word I'm happy
for you that you let it ferment and and
brought it when it was ready
yeah I you know I um
I know that there are there are people
who respond to the album and say Hey you
voicing these things you articulating
these things that I've been thinking is
has was the last straw for me of
admitting that I have deconstructed or I
am leaving the church or whatever so I
do I'm not ignorant of the fact that
this type of art does have influence
yeah and and in many of those cases I'm
I obviously celebrate if people are
moving out of an oppressive oppressive
belief system that's something to be
celebrated but that was that's not the
intention of it you're just reporting
what is happening yeah but by the way
Richard Rohr alert I love Richard Rohr
he wrote a book called um order disorder
reorder I don't think that's what it's
called but it's like the Edge of
Tomorrow we actually call it lived I
repeat
but the subtitle is I think it's called
the it doesn't matter
forgive me meaning I'm not gonna get it
I can just tell
but um I can see the cover of the book
but order to sort of reorder anything
worth having I I'm saying this by the
way when you're 20 if you disagree with
me you absolutely should disagree with
me this is an old man [__] you recognize
that you didn't even have it until you
broke it lost it smashed it lit it on
fire walked away from it 99.9 of the
people that I interact with and there
and they just kind of like hold on to
their their nothing and by the way
that's that's fine
um but if if there's a reconstruction by
the way everyone listening to this
podcast knows I'm all about that
reconstruction because it's been so good
for me not not a thought system belief
system symbol system nothing to sell but
um meaning There's No Agenda I just want
you to feel safe yeah I found so much
value you just referenced Eckhart Tolle
great great we talked about that last
time yeah if you're going to replace
um something that was dogmatic or
repressive or let's be honest fear fear
inducing yep I'm not saying for
everybody for me
the whole thing was very scary
when when you get safe to look at it Not
only was it scary it tensed me up and I
had to defend it and all like your songs
say it's like I just don't have time for
these inconvenient truths and all that
sort of stuff so I was the opposite of
spacious free flowing everything that by
the way I think Christ was by the way
just like a free man like if there's
anything he was or enlightened beings
are they're free yeah I wasn't free I
was really trying to keep a little
candle lit and it was raining really
hard yeah and that sucks Eckhart Tolle
obviously when people reach out to me
and they're like I'm not religious
I don't want religious language that's
traumatic to me I always go read The
Power of Now read the poem now or or a
new Earth they're both pretty much the
same yeah and I you know it's funny
because I I think um
one of the interesting things has been
watching the way I think just the
because of the I'm interested this
happened to you you you you you happen
at a different time with you but because
so many Christians thought we were on
their team for so long and then our
deconstruction happened publicly and
relatively recently you know when we're
just like we're you know social media in
what it is now
just all the interpretations of what it
is that
happened to us and happened to me and
the and especially because my
deconstruction the way that I
articulated it was very much just like
these are the intellectual steps that I
went through to sort of where I began to
lose Faith where Link's story is very
much like this is my sort of emotional
journey through this and there's you
know that there's two sides of the same
coin in a lot of ways for every
therapist Point yours is you're top down
he's bottom up yeah exactly
um but it's been interesting for people
to say oh so you're now an oh you're
open spiritual like trying to find a box
to way to just to describe
what I'm what My Philosophy is and I'm
just like I don't
I don't I'm trying not to articulate a
philosophy yeah if if that makes sense
I mean there's a part of me that really
wants to like organize it and put it
together and be like this is it this is
what I think and then defend the wall
around it but that's the thing that I'm
really trying to avoid but defining it
and defending it I was thinking about it
on the way down ROM to us boom a little
pic of him what you guys can't see it
sorry give it a goog
um I was thinking about him today
probably because of your album
and how one of my favorite things he
says he goes you don't want to be Jewish
you want to be free you don't want to be
Christian you want to be free you don't
even want to be an atheist you want to
be free but you want to you atheism is a
wonderful uh potential strategy for
getting rid of fear getting rid of guilt
getting rid of Shame and that way it can
be incredibly liberating to me my
journey didn't end there I kept going
yeah but like what's also interesting
about that I'm very I you know I'm on I
don't want to say I'm on a non-dual kick
my stuff has led me to the it's all one
place yeah so even the attempts to kind
of get you to Define yourself is also
just a continuation of Illusion and
separateness and
um divisiveness attack meaning as soon
as I can call you what you are then I
can attack you or join with you and
either way both of those are negations
of the Oneness so the more spacious and
the more clear you are which by the way
is who you are when you are in the a
moment when you're not calling up your
your documents and reading them and go
like this is these are this is my
mission statement when you put that
aside or is it Rupert spiral would say
who are you in between the two like
let's say you're telling me your beliefs
between belief a and belief B where were
you and who are you in that in that Gap
and the more I'm on this path the more
I'm like it's all the Gap because let me
tell you what you are in the Gap
innocent Guiltless unafraid connected
identity-less yeah spacious and free and
that's all of us and and the words that
get you there
just tell me what got you away from Fear
yeah that would be nice not I'm not
saying to you yeah and you're the and
you're the same person I think is an
important part of that too right like
you mean after the transition yes like
you you you think differently you may
behave differently you may you you may
see things very differently but at your
core
it's that same little boy yeah that's
right still a little rep you know what
I'm saying well this is Richard Roy's
idea of transcendent include meaning
transcend I've transcended it doesn't
mean I've
stomped on and and peed on the ashes my
past you can transcend and include it
meaning you're talking to
there's there is a fundamentalist little
boy here too you know what I mean and
he's okay he came with me right because
it all comes with me yeah because
anything else wouldn't be free it's not
free to act like that didn't happen yeah
yeah it's just it's such a the way that
it's characterized with like you okay
you've changed you know California
doesn't look good on you you know it's
like that's hurtful the cliches are just
I mean look at that it's a territory
it's like a belief is like a territory a
body is like a territory it's a clan it
by Clan I don't mean the clan I mean
like it's a tribe yeah and now they're
saying you've left your tribe which by
the way
the reason why that might be so
upsetting because it was upsetting to me
for you to just give that as an example
yeah is what you're really saying is
um You're Not Safe you're gonna die
like I I really think it's like you've
left Georgia North Carolina whatever you
want to say your tribe is you've left
our belief system we no longer got you
it's a murderous thought
it's a thought it's a violent thought
yeah on a man like a primal level I'm
saying California doesn't look good on
you meaning you're alone in the
wilderness meaning I really I mean this
literally like in that language is if
wolves attack you we don't got you yeah
and there's a part of you that thinks
that's important because you don't know
you live in the 21st century yeah yeah
and the and the the other piece of it is
the ah this is sad yeah it's so sad
and you know and it's just a
and you know and I'll look at the the
responses and you know we're talking 99
people are like this really resonates
with me I I I because so many people are
in this boat right yeah sure and and
that's been the you know the most
beautiful part of this thing is people's
stories but you see that
oh this is sad and you just you just
want to be like well just let's just
this is the this is the Evangelical
conservative inside me just I just want
to sit down with you and talk yeah over
coffee and show you show you that I'm
not sad yeah this is and I'm not sad and
I this is good yeah this is good
you really do have to
just as gone as that is for you
it's that ethereal and
transitory what I'm saying is
you might as well be talking to yourself
in the past yeah and just as things
change I say this all the time but
spirituality isn't interested in what
doesn't change and beliefs change and
thoughts change yeah
um but that's that's got to be tricky
yeah those one the the nasty ones yeah
and it's just you know figuring out how
to to navigate it because like I said I
I'm in I'm a naturally
um persuasive I go into pretty
persuasive mode right I just deleted I
was gonna be like don't you think that
the other Jews thought it was weird that
Jesus got baptized by John the Baptist
John the Baptist was essentially when I
say cult I don't mean like it was a bad
cult but he was essentially a cult
leader you think
other Jews didn't look down on G that's
the whole story right
yeah order disorder reorder yeah it it
was true for him as well and so should
it be for you everybody just wants to
jump to the end of the line and be like
I've been converted guess what guys
Jesus says I bring no sign except the
sign of Jonah what happened to Jonah he
got it eaten by a whale that's that's
disorder
yeah that's Darkness that's Recon that's
deconstruction and he's telling you in
in black and white or red if he had one
of those Bibles that's the only way my
dad was a Gideon
Gideons the hotel people
we all want to just jump to conversion
without the experience but it turns out
the the the pain The Suffering The Sign
of Jonah is the only way to do it yeah
but we just want to go like no you can
just believe your way around it
yeah I look like I I remember mocking
somebody that said I don't think you can
know love meaning relational love until
you've had your heart broken I roasted
this guy because I was 20 years old and
I didn't believe that and I remember I
got this huge laugh I was like that's
like saying you can't enjoy a dog until
you've had a dog that died and I'm like
now I'm like you can't enjoy it until
you've had a dog that died yeah right
like I was [__] wrong well you can't
enjoy the dog on the level on the level
yeah I'll concede you can have
relationship before your heart is broken
but I don't think and again
I think big truths come through humility
only the penitent man will pass like
your humility to Bow and say I don't
know is a far more if this means
anything to you
useful energy then coming at God and
telling God what he is or it is or yeah
well shouting at that that's a big thing
as of late that you know I I see the
more thoughtful uh people in the
Evangelical Community who are actually
responding in more helpful ways to
what's happening because they're they're
panicking a lot right with with the
number of people that are adios you know
so oh yeah one of the things that you
see is that and I have I have you know
isn't it funny that adios means to God
foreign
but this idea that the thing that I'm
Giving Up on is Mystery right like that
the thoughtful Evangelical response
right now is that you guys are letting
your doubts overwhelm you to the place
where you're not you're bypassing the
mystery of God whereas hey I also doubt
this is from their perspective I also
have doubts and I also don't know if I'm
right but I choose to lean on the solid
rock of Jesus and lean into the mystery
and and that's that sounds great it also
doesn't sound like mystery to me but
yeah it's like well so what you're
telling me is that you're embracing the
mystery except for the the basically the
bottom line that really matters and that
is that you've got Jesus figured out
you've got God figured out and this is
the only way to connect with God to go
back to what we're saying saying it is
certainty worship yes nobody wants to
buy a mystery nobody wants to buy a
relationship certainly nobody wants to
buy conversion nobody wants to buy the
sign of Jonah right and it would I'm
just saying you P you peel that one
additional I'm sure there's additional
layers but I just feel like there's one
layer of sort of protection that they're
not willing willing to shed yeah and be
like what is truly letting go looking
like I would go so far as to say because
to lose that rock
uh which by the way I relate to I spent
a lot of my life that way is to open
yourself up to this intense fear of a
God that you think might
kill you might destroy not only kill you
destroy you torture you like it's like
you have to come to terms with the scary
drunk dad God that he's coming home he's
shit-faced and you saw what he did to
his son and he did that for us oh this
is a scary dude yeah and that's not a
safe conversation to have no
so you know I'm just gonna I get it I
get it yeah and I and I ultimately I
think
while I enjoy
talking about these things
the music has been a good it's better
Outlet because it's even though the
music is pretty you know my the lyrics
are
there's some there's some poetry in the
lyrics but that you kind of know what
I'm talking about I'm not hiding a whole
lot right I'm they do sort of sound like
a breakup which is so funny yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah I know it's country but
it reminds me most of uh sea change the
Beck album yeah and that's a that's a
breakup album and this sounds like a
breakup album more yeah in fact I'm sure
there are people facts that are out
there just going through a heartbreak
though oh yeah that's my answer right
now exactly because it's the same thing
yeah Love Is Love Is Love losses losses
Lots but yeah and I think that because
when it's so much I keep falling into
the
the the uh the Trap of trying to Define
and defend when I talk about it a lot
but when you what is news when you when
you write a song about it it's better no
it's one of my least I try not to do it
is when I have musicians on or even
authors sometimes you ask them the
question and the question is the
question that the book answers yeah and
you're like the reason I wrote a book is
because it takes nine hours to answer
that question and now I'm just supposed
to do it on Good Morning America yeah
yeah work so let the music be the music
all right the record's incredible love
it proud I mean it's weird to say I'm
proud of you but I'm proud of you and
thank you for being vulnerable and
sharing it
um have you ever this is just kind of
like since you did it last time there
are questions I like to ask every time
yeah yeah
ever seen a ghost
no UFO
I don't think so
ever almost die uh yeah
um
the closest I would say
kayaking accident in high school
we would
um
and this is link and I because we've
known each other since 1984.
um in the small town of buoys Creek when
the creek would flood we would grab our
kayaks which we did not know how to
operate yeah could not flip them didn't
have helmets didn't have life jackets
the the kayak that I had didn't even
have floatation you know you had there's
like flotation stuff inside of a kayak
to keep it afloat I had taken trash bags
and filled them up with uh like packing
peanuts and foam and put them in the
kayak that was my flotation
so the creek flooded
and uh it was one of those situations
where well I I fell out and when you
fall out of the kayak you just swim away
from it but it was the creek was the
very high flood stage because you don't
want it to hit you yeah and so but there
was a a log that was just under the knee
underneath the surface of the water that
you couldn't really see that I
was penned up against and then the kayak
got on my back and started filling with
water and pinning me against the tree
and I was like I'm going to die here oh
no that's like a scene in the gray yeah
see the gray yes well and I'm like
waving
and Link and Ben my friends are just
like a hundred yards down the creek and
they see me they just looks like I'm
standing in the creek waving who had
that story Katie that someone else had a
story that was like it's such a shame
that this means hello and yeah it's like
yeah I didn't know the internet there is
a sign for drowning but I don't know
what it is I know this means I'm out of
air but that's too subtle there's got to
be something you could do with your hand
it should be like surface of water
I'm such a loser I'm dying
um but it eventually filled up with
water to the point where it started
moving down
and before I like ran out of breath it
goes under the log and I come back up so
I think that I'm sure I've been closer
to death and underwater I think no so my
head and shoulders and arms were still
out of the water above the tree but I
couldn't breathe and so I was like this
thing is just going to fill with water
pin me against this they're going to
watch me slowly just fall asleep not
only am I going to die but I'm going to
die with link waving
he's sleepy yeah oh my God I almost said
what an idiot but I would have done the
same thing I would be like hi buddy
terrifying yeah didn't die but I have
not but the UFO thing I'm asking so you
didn't die though I didn't die I'm still
here the uh the ghost thing never never
anything close to it like I I I I kind
of I'm interested I I open I'm open yeah
um
in the UFO thing
I'm also very open just given the state
of the world and every and I've got I've
got so many close friends who are like
you know sending me
every little thing every little update
every little like Senate hearing or
whatever this stuff kind of progresses
like see I told you yeah I'm not crazy I
know and it's like page 17 News because
like Trump calls Pringles
ugly chips and then 15 pages through
we're like
first of all the guy on the Pringles can
he's not a looker he looks like an
all-time Barber yeah right two there's
UFOs
yeah I mean I just I'm so I just want to
know though yeah you know I'm well I'd
love to I'd like to see one but I would
be scared too obviously like basic I'm
not such a basic B I'm just like but I'd
be scared thanks Pete thank you so much
uh anything you can't explain happen to
you meaning
I just had a an akashic reading which is
is sort of like a I'm only saying this
it's not a psychic but it's sort of like
it's like and she was nailing my life
like saying things that that nobody
knows that I don't talk about on the
podcast don't pose about stuff that like
I shared this recently because it was
after the fact
never had a writing partner I'm writing
something with a partner right now she
knew that she knew that he's a huge
baseball fan he's a huge Dodger fan he's
always throwing a baseball when we're
writing I'm like this is crazy and by
the way just because I enjoy
snoping it out it's not like she knew
for months that we were going to have
the reading and she like hacked zoom and
watched it I mean like maybe uh but
that's off the table because it was like
a very quick like let's do it meet bam
nailed it anything like that or anything
you just can't explain ever happened
yeah so I I have not I actually want to
do like link and I were talking about
doing something
um
with a medium
um maybe next year that would be you
know a little bit funny but also like
legitimately like trying to connect with
something that's fun um just because I
I've done some reading about that and
essentially you know the conclusion I've
come to is that there's just some things
that
can't quite explain like there's too
many experiences that people
what I've always believed is oh this is
just people's minds Playing Tricks on
them yeah and there's still a big part
of me that thinks that that might be
true because I haven't experienced
anything
directly that I can't explain but I'm
also like I don't know there's got to be
something going on but one thing that
happened
uh my wife and I were in were in bed
sleeping and both having a dream
uh and in
I told her I told I won't remember all
the details thankfully this is captured
on the internet somewhere but we were
essentially both having a dream and in
my dream which I do remember is there
was an elevator door that opened up and
there was a little blonde girl standing
there and you know just like a scary
little blonde girl like they typically
are in horror movies yeah in an elevator
yeah and
I woke up she wakes up at the same time
she tells me her dream and there was a
little blonde girl in her dream that had
woken her up at the same time whoa
that's a spicy chicken sandwich so
here's here's what's going on there when
you say playing with your mind we're not
going to get into this we're wrapping up
we're Landing the plane you know it's
okay the stewardesses are sitting down
or stewards they're sitting down uh you
know they're in their jump seats we're
almost on the ground we're almost done
you're almost at it you cannot use the
bathroom at this point you're gonna go
catch a fish with your bare hands or
whatever it is yeah
you can't use the bathroom sorry to hear
your roof
um but Mind Playing Tricks on her you
and your wife having this
co-experience my experience with the
psychic uh akashic reader
all of this one little comment
we don't know what our minds are I think
it's so funny that we all just go like
it's just your mind playing tricks on
you it's just a coincidence when the
mechanism with which we're noticing
coincidence coincidence is a mystery to
us right like Joan of Arc when they were
killing her they said you speak to God
in your mind and she said how else would
I talk to him
that to me I know that's maybe intense
but I'm like no she's absolutely right
well where else would you meet awareness
but in awareness and also if that is the
case if we all are sharing one
Consciousness that the implications of
that explain a lot of what you're
talking about well do you know about I
think it might be called the so it's
essentially if it's not this it's
something that sounds just like it like
the the association of people who Hear
Voices or something like that do you
know about this have you heard about
this Earwolf
hmm
it's a group of people
who are not
clinically insane right they haven't Yep
they're not your voice feel yeah
and
I I was I can't remember what book it
was but the guy was talking about Joan
of Arc and then you saying that there's
more and more people recognizing that
there there are people who
yeah
exactly the the idea of maybe the mind
maybe this is part of you know this is
mind we both know uh science Mike in the
way that he talks about the
um
he's like if there's
he's much more articular than I am but
if there's something that is
Supernatural
well that's probably just natural right
that's probably an element of
our existence that we don't yet
understand and that would include things
like
ghosts UFOs hearing voices like if those
things are legitimate and it isn't it
isn't just something that's completely
isolated in the mind yeah well it's
still something that is in the mind the
mind is perceiving that's right your own
voice
the fact that your own voice
is normal to hear
is insane to me yeah like that we're all
not just like wondering about that like
if I hear Pete's Voice or my own thought
feeling and I'm like I hear that got it
where do your thoughts come from and
where they recede into is a really good
question to ask yourself before you have
a nice sit or or smoke yeah because it's
really worth looking at and it's the
it's the foundation upon which
everything is built and no one's really
to my satisfaction talking about it
except all the people that I found
Rupert spirack are totally these this is
why the draw towards spirit is is like
that's the biggest question
I'm currently working my way through A
Course in Miracles I love I love it and
it was channeled it was channeled by a
voice that identified itself as Jesus
it's really interesting right I'm
looking into the story it was like a
non-spiritual atheist person there was a
professor at Columbia I believe and just
started writing down what this voice was
saying and by the way this is a whole
genre of books uh Hicks there's like
Abraham Hicks there's the Seth books
what is going on here like yeah are we
just gonna just dismiss it and just be
like this is nothing I'm telling you
it's the first channeled book I've read
of Course in Miracles and I'm like this
is uh fiercely consistent and very
I would say like sharp incredibly
Diamond like meaning if if someone wrote
this quickly if it's true sure you could
say well then it's not true okay fine
let's let's yeah that is in the realm of
things that could happen but when you
read it you're like if it did happen the
way they said it happened uh this is
crazy if this if this is this just
poured out of someone like we should pay
attention and people do pay attention
yeah and to not have to
um one of the best parts about no longer
thinking the way I used to think is not
having to uh dismiss it out right
dismiss it outright or immediately file
it away into a pre-existing file cabinet
called Satan right dude the funniest
thing about the Course in Miracles is
it's like I know I know you're gonna
dismiss that like it it dresses the kind
of programming that we have and we do
even you're talking about like you and
Link maybe getting a medium you and I
are from a place where we're like watch
watch how oh yeah yeah it was all again
it's another sort of fear of Base like
you can't
if you don't write
on the void if you don't fill that void
with all of these writings if you erase
those writings
something else is going to swoop in and
write something bad on it like something
something dangerous something that's
going to kill you right it's and that's
a that's a weird
it's a not spacious place no it's not
yeah
um all right let me see if I'm
forgetting any questions Parenthood who
cares
that was a joke uh you were in beauty
pageants that was unqualified is that
true
uh you were little
um I was in Mr harness Central what is
it Mr Harnett Central it was the men's
pageant that featured Juniors and
seniors at our high school both me and
Link were both in it
anyway I picture juniors in high school
and the elderly Community for some
reason that's how my mind took it I was
like really but neither of us neither of
us won in yeah
Who's laughing now I think I got it all
man I mean just to make you feel
appreciated I wrote down built a house
at 16 bed wetter nosebleeds beauty
pageants your mom Slovakia you used to
get up and read YouTube comments
you're obsessed with apocalypse all true
prep Hot Yoga juicing [__] enough
horror novels Ultra Lights what are
ultralights the little um little planes
I I'm not I'm I was obsessed with them
I've never even been in one it's like
the little uh drones little trikes no
you're there's a person in it but
there's like a fan behind you basically
oh ultralights yeah light isn't light
not as in bright yes I gotcha yeah but I
feel completely satisfied we don't have
to do any tune into good mythical
morning if you want to hear more about
it yeah I'm sure I'll get into it either
I think that's why it was readily
available but we talked about stuff
we've never talked about right and that
was great so thanks so much man the
album is called you said it's human
overboard I knew it was from James and
the shame I'm using I'm not using if you
search
but human overboard James and the shame
yep and it's fantastic and here's the
last question
can you I'm sure you have lots which is
a great life but can you tell me a time
in your life when you laughed really
really really really hard like you cried
laughing here's a few prompts because
everybody you might freeze up first of
all gonna take you right off the hook it
doesn't have to be a great story
how old are you maybe you're a kid maybe
someone farted maybe someone fell down
um I will say this isn't nice I don't
tend to like if it's a movie if people
are just like Ace Ventura just to nudge
you away from that I'd rather someone
poop their pants or something like that
you know what I'm saying so uh anything
come to mind uh yeah it's you know
I'm trying to think of a specific moment
from so link and I make each other laugh
legitimately all the time right I know
yeah that's why I knew it would be hard
but
we were talking about some of the times
that we remember that being
um becoming a part of our friendship and
we had a friend uh Ben was his name
growing up together
and
the three of us would just
you know the you
know the stuff that Middle School boys
laugh at that doesn't work that well and
and even beyond that I can't remember
any I'm this isn't going to be
satisfying but I think about the because
I don't remember a specific joke that
Ben told or something that he would say
but we sort of codified this
laughing
to the point where you're laughing at
the fact that you're laughing
no one has ever said this in their
answer but the category of laughing and
then you're laughing because you're
laughing
we need a word for that because that's
what makes me happy remember we just
caught link and I just caught it a laugh
attack right laugh attack and so there's
been a few you know this doesn't this
doesn't happen often we'll laugh at each
other but we in middle school we would
laugh at each other you would forget
what you were laughing at and you would
see the other guy laughing and you would
laugh just keep laughing and it was
until it hurt
yeah this is like laugh yoga yes that's
a good method yes you got to do some
laugh yoga and there's the Laughing
churches too where they do this do you
know about those that's probably the
same thing right you just induce a fit
of Holy Spirit yes yes and it just is
just insane
um I bet it feels great so I would say
that that those are the most memorable
times is the laughing at the laughter
itself
beautiful that took me back it really
did to like Junior High it also made me
think of one I remember we still say
this my friend Thomas and Erin and our
friend Dan Xiao we were having a we used
to put sleeping bags over our heads and
and fight fight is generous like that
sounds like we were like The Boondock
Saints we weren't that we're just little
boys but would put to be blind in his
basement Tom's Basement and I remember
for some reason Dan Shao
his uh move was he'd plant his hands on
the ground and do a like a kick like it
like you know what a weird move yeah
and I ca I said
what is this mule kick yeah I was gonna
say donkey kick that's what I wanted a
donkey kick but I said mule kick and if
I
called uh Tom or Ern and said what is
this or something they'd say mule kicked
this is milking and I think that was one
of the times we laughed and then laughed
because we were laughing also you got to
be different in every way Dan you're
smarter than all of us it was a very he
was like like a little grown-up right he
was like I know how to beat these fools
hey and that's how that's how Ben was
was he we always talk about that before
the internet
he had all this information
[Laughter]
it's like where do you get information
yeah the library yeah
I'm telling you as soon as as soon as
they've been in Jerry's information with
pornography we all got smarter yeah
right yes knowing things just doesn't
it's not impressive anymore no no it's
meaningless 16 ounces it's a pound of
cheese
well rep thank you
what a delight for me
the different you were hilarious and
wonderful last time but to see you just
be um
solid it's nice and open thanks for
having me in this way and being able to
talk about it yeah I appreciate you
creating a love seat for us of course
yeah we make it a love seat uh and I and
we'll talk again in a year when you're
when you're just talking about
everything
okay uh would you say keep it crispy
it's how we end keep it crispy that was
the briefest explanation usually takes
me 10 minutes thanks man
you ready
oh yeah
[Music]